okay I've got to talk to you about
something we have been doing now for
three years running these David Pakman
show
calendars and we usually make them
available sort of in mid-november a few
days before Thanksgiving often and they
are calendars for the following year I
was initially not going to do one for
2018 we've just been so busy and we've
had so much going on because of YouTube
the monetization crisis and so many
other things but people have started to
email me saying David are you going to
do a 2018 calendar I've been getting
ready to buy one usually they're made
available in November so I'm coming to
you with the following question do you
want us to do a 2018 david pakman show
calendar and as a reminder we had the
2015 calendar that we first made
available in late 2014 that was a hatred
mail themed calendar all hatred mail
related 2016's calendar was also a
hatred mail related calendar and then
last year's or I guess this year's which
we made available at the end of 2016 was
a comic book themed calendar with really
really great comic book art from david
pakman show viewer Dan Burke so where
are we today I am more than willing to
do a 20-18 calendar the problem is we
don't have artwork for it right I can't
just recycle or I wouldn't want to it
wouldn't be fair to the audience to
recycle artwork that we've used in the
past so we need you collectively to put
together twelve images one for each
month of the year plus a cover now how
can you contribute well you can
contribute any 1920 by 1080 show related
image it could be a new hatred mail
graphic that could be included on the
calendar and then also used at the
beginning of hatred mail segments it
could be a meme related to the show it
could be any other type of artwork a
cartoon a caricature whatever the only
requirement is it has to somehow be
related to the david pakman show or
politics in some way that kind of
connects with the show as well if people
want it we do need to start gathering
the images sooner than later
realistically we want to have the
calendars on sale I would say by
Thanksgiving so that we can have a full
so
five weeks of calendar sales I'm more
than glad to do it I just lack I
completely lack the artistic ability to
do this so I need your help you don't
need to contribute all 13 images right
if we can get 13 people to do one image
each we will be in good shape for the
calendar so that's where we are and at
first I wasn't even going to mention it
but so many people have been emailing me
that I figure it's worthwhile to at
least tell you why we have not talked
about it so far and open up for
submission you can send those images to
david at david pakman.com the only
requirement is make the image 1920 by
1080 and that will be the right format
for our calendar and that's it let's see
if we can put it together